good day and welcome i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia
please allow me to welcome you to this
edition of our 2020 2021
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series
our speaker today is dr lucina wooden
she is associate professor
at the university of miami where she's
also the director of the cognitive and
behavioral neuroscience division
in 2001 she completed her bachelor of
science degree in neuroscience and
philosophy at the university of
california in los angeles
and completing her phd work in cognitive
and uh psycho psychological neuroscience
at the university
of california los angeles uh in 2006.
her professional experience includes
postdoctoral fellows
fellowships at new york university and
stanford university
and since 2014 has been a faculty member
at the university of miami
at miami she leads the brain
connectivity and cognition laboratory
which employs neuroimaging and
accompanying methods to examine the
relationship between brain connectivity
and cognition in typical and atypical
development
many of her her long list of
accomplishments includes
the university of miami de belli senior
scholar award
the universal scientific education and
research network
laureate in medical sciences the
organization for human brain mappings
young investigator award
and several others her lecture today is
entitled neuroinformatics and cognitive
ontologies
and we are very excited to welcome her
to our our
series now before we begin as you uh as
always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via youtube if
you are watching on youtube
thank you for joining us also our
specially selected
2020-2021 biomedical data science
innovation lab participants
are encouraged to submit any questions
for dr uden via the chat feature
of their zoom sessions i'll synthesize
these questions and ask them on your
behalf during the last 10 minutes or so
of dr uden's talk uh with that welcome
lucina
we are very much looking forward to your
election
thanks very much uh dr van horn it's
really a pleasure to be here
virtually with all of you um share some
of our work in this area and i
do wish i could be there in person for
all of these different
activities but um until then the uh the
virtual format will have to do
so um what i'd like to share with you
today is just some
some thoughts and some data about the
topic of neuroinformatics and cognitive
ontologies
so for those of us working in cognitive
neuroscience we know that
there have been decades and decades of
fmri
functional magnetic resonance imaging
work that's identified distinct patterns
of brain activation that occur while
participants perform
different kinds of cognitive tasks and
the goal of course is to map
the areas of the brain that are involved
in different types of cognitive
processes
um sort of the goal of cognitive
neuroscience very broadly
and uh what we would like to suggest
here today is that these data can in
principle
be used to provide the basis for
constructing a biologically informed
data-driven ontology or taxonomy of
psychological processes and there's many
others who've worked in this area too
over the years and i'll draw on some of
that literature uh
as well so in this talk i'd like to
highlight some of the progress
and challenges associated with the
construction of cognitive ontologies
using informatics approaches and
based on functional neuroimaging data
so let me go the right direction
let's see okay so what is a cognitive
ontology
um so an ontology generally is a branch
of philosophy that deals
with the nature and organization of
reality so what things are there
in the world out there how do we carve
up nature at its joints that's really
what ontology deals with
um and so a cognitive ontology then
would be a formal description
of concepts that are assumed to exist
within a particular domain here we're
talking about
psychology and the interrelationships
between them
so uh one sort of easy way of thinking
about ontologies is just
what are knowledge structures that we
you know know about
uh that we use to communicate amongst
each other so
you know we just saw the the nba finals
with the the lakers uh coming out as
champs again
um and if you think about an ontology of
the nba you have
things like basic units like players
that belong to teams
and you have a western conference and an
eastern conference and knowing this
knowledge structure tells you that
in the finals you're going to have a
team from the west to play a team from
the east because that's a structure of
the nba
and knowing all the things we do about
teams and their compositions
and the players that make them up it
tells us something about
what we can expect in any uh you know
given category to contain
so just knowledge of the way the nba
works is a particular ontology and just
like that we
we have these sort of knowledge
structures in in various domains
so you know in the case of of cognitive
ontology we might uh
think about something like a particular
task and how we should categorize that
so many people use these simple task
paradigms
the flanker task is one in which the
participant is asked
look at the arrow in the center and tell
me if it's
pointing to the left or pointing to the
right and you use a button press to
indicate your response
and the challenge of this task is
sometimes there's flankers to that
central arrow going in opposite
direction
and um you know anytime you do this
behavioral paradigm it slows people down
when there are
arrows uh pointing in the opposite
direction of the center arrow
this task has been around for a long
time and we use it um
you know in the laboratory uh and the
question is what what are we using this
task for what process
what cognitive process do we think we're
tapping when we do a task like this
and a cognitive ontology the research in
this area would actually formalize
this kind of question so if you had for
example uh
so if you had one individual who says
well this is a response inhibition test
that's what we're measuring here the
cognitive construct of response
inhibition
and then you might have another
scientist say no what we're really
looking at when we ask people to do this
is error detection
that's what i think the flanker task is
mapping and
in what we do when we look at cognitive
ontology
research is formalize this type of
disagreement into a research program
where you know we can say well let's
figure
out what it what cognitive construct or
process is this task really tapping and
how do we get to the answer to that
question
uh what what is a way to sort of uh
create a better
cognitive ontology or categorization of
these
mental and uh psychological constructs
so there's several approaches for
constructing cognitive ontologies and
they can sort of broadly fall into the
category of
bottom up top bottom up and top down so
a top-down approach is where you would
use
expert knowledge and opinion to um you
know get a group of researchers to agree
well when you do this task
what you're really engaging is this
cognitive construct and now we all agree
on that
and we can write it down and use it to
communicate um so there's been a lot of
work in this area
using expert opinion and topic modeling
of texts
in article databases you'll see some of
the references here
russ boldreck's group ng laird and
jessica turner
italian have done a lot of this work um
at
building a top-down sort of cognitive
ontology and of course the benefit to
something like that is that you can
you know produce a detailed ontology of
relationships and
entities but there is of course the
downside that this may
fail to map on to actual divisions or
categories of nature
and uh and there's some other downsides
that i'll mention in in a minute
but um this has been one sort of popular
approach for construction
of a cognitive ontology and on the other
hand you have this bottom-up approaches
it's usually
a data-driven or more informatics-based
approach so data-driven classification
or clustering of functional imaging or
behavioral data
and you can also uh you know use
supervised machine learning for this
type of thing
or exploratory unsupervised machine
learning
and uh this this bottom-up approach
basically um you know can try to derive
cognitive processed categories of
cognitive processes directly from task
fmri
patterns and the pros of this is that
this
an ontology derived in this matter might
more likely reflect
actual divisions or categories of nature
that we see um
but they may not necessarily provide
enough detail to be a practical use for
knowledge representation
so um you know every sort of approach
has
has its pros and cons so one example
just to
you know that many people might be
familiar with is of a top-down approach
is this research
domain criteria that the national
institute of health has um
sort of put forth and this is a way it's
a sort of a call for new ways of
classifying mental illness
that are based on dimensions of
observable behavior and neurobiological
measures um
and other measures and this is uh just a
real
um kind of summary of some of the
categories within
the research domain criteria uh back in
2016 i was part of this
cognitive group the blue group here in
the middle um that
basically it was a group of experts who
decided what the categories were that
would be of use for study um you know to
standardize across
uh psychiatric disorders and uh to push
forward
uh personalized medicine and so forth
and being on the panel of
you know on this top-down panel made me
realize sort of firsthand what were some
of the
downsides of doing the top-down approach
and one of them
is of course everyone who studies uh
cognitive neuroscience has their own
biases and their own sort of lifetime of
ways of thinking about things and
so expert based approaches are um prone
to
the kinds of biases that experts have so
you may be a person who studies
executive function so you think
these particular aspects of cognition
are the most important or the most
salient or the most interesting for
investigation
it doesn't necessarily mean that's the
way the brain is carved up or that's the
way that the
mind works but um so you know that this
was a top-down
kind of ontological approach
um but the reason that this sort of
research domain criteria has been so
popular is that the goal was to carve up
psychiatric disorders in a way that's
not just symptom-based so it's not just
you see a person with observable
symptoms in this manner and you
put them into major depression or
bipolar or some other category
because you know of course symptoms
themselves cannot tell you much about
the underlying mechanism so
perhaps if you look at genetic risks
brain activity physiology behavior
and life experience and uh derived
data-driven clusters of individuals who
are more similar within cluster
than a cross cluster those those people
might not all fall into the category of
major depressive disorder but they might
all
be most uh well treated by a particular
type of
of drug or intervention um because once
you've identified clusters that are more
homogeneous the
treatment know kind of response research
can be more targeted and hopefully more
uh efficient so rdoc has really prompted
individuals in the field of psychiatry
to rethink how psychopathology might be
best served by building
a framework that's based more on
biological and cognitive
validity um so you know a lot of people
working
with the rdoc framework now look for
research findings that cut across
diagnostic boundaries
and uh you know this is all towards the
sort of goal of precision medicine so
that you can see why you know
despite there being flaws in the top
down approach there there's been a lot
of success
with this uh method and
um there's been a lot of work uh this
was from russ pauldrag and talia irconi
trying to derive things like cognitive
atlases which
carve up the space of uh you know
of all the different cognitive
constructs in a way that lets us
use a common language to communicate
about them so this cognitive atlas
project is basically
a collaborative knowledge building
project aimed at developing
an ontology characterizing the current
state of cognitive neuroscience
and so this nice paper uh summarizes
some of the
constructs you see all the time
cognitive control working memory
executive uh you know function and what
tasks measure
them um that tasks that we use as
scientists um
and sort of how the different things map
onto each other
based on basically what the field is
already doing so this is just a summary
of what
is actually going on in cognitive
psychology and cognitive neuroscience
and cognitive sciences more broadly
um and as you can see uh this you know
similar to what ardoc is trying to do
the goal here is that if you
uh you know understand a particular
process like response inhibition
um which we then map onto a brain region
which we think well ventrilateral
prefrontal cortex seems to be involved
um then you can look at things like
signaling pathways
genes that contribute to uh function of
those regions
and then at the highest level syndromes
in which that particular function
is disrupted and cutting across
different diagnoses as well so
all these projects um kind of get at the
same goal of relating biological
functions and processes
eventually to things like psychiatric
syndromes
a similar effort is called the cognitive
paradigm ontology
put forth by jessica turner and angela
laird
and this was based on a
drawing from the taxonomy of the brain
map project which many of you are
probably familiar with the brain map
database
includes uh coordinates from you know
thousands and thousands of task
activation studies
um that have been coded in particular
ways
um and what the cognitive paradigm
ontology does is
represent the characteristics of the
cognitive paradigms that have been used
in fmri literature
over the years so this is a uh
the brain map database itself includes
these categories like
the experimental paradigm that was used
and uh
the type of stimulus the response type
um
you know uh all these different sort of
categories um that are used to
characterize
the broad you know the broad
database of fmri studies that are
available today
so this is another sort of a way of
organizing what's
what's out there
and this is just one example that i like
why am i going backwards there we go uh
another example i like of uh trying to
identify cognitive components from
neuroimaging work
um from thomas joe's group and uh here
he um
basically used an author topic
hierarchical vision modeling
uh approach to uh applied this to
contrast from the brain map database
to derive what he's called here
cognitive components that
you know may contribute to performance
of specific tasks like working memory or
attention tests
um and a very nice sort of mapping
between experiment
tasks cognitive components and the brain
regions involved this is very
interesting paper that i recommend for
for those um who want more on this topic
the reason i particularly like this
paper is because he
um he quantified um what brain regions
use the most number of cognitive
components and really interestingly
there's
uh the areas here in red you see one of
them is the anterior insula
is basically uh activated in many many
many
tasks and paradigms and experiments and
as you can see it's
it's got a very high number of cognitive
components
a lot of my work uh in the lab that i'm
not going to be talking about today
focuses on the role of the anterior
insulin
brain network dynamics and i think it's
just very interesting that you can use
completely
data-driven approaches to show the same
thing that we've been doing
uh using things like meta-analytic
connectivity
um modeling and uh dynamic functional
connectivity look at
the flexibility of the insular region
and here you can see the flexibility
uh here is associated with the fact that
this region just participates
in all kinds of uh all manner of tasks
so really interesting findings
um and so what we uh
you know what i'm gearing up to tell you
about today is some of the work that
taylor bolt in the lab did when he was a
phd student
and he left the lab a few years ago and
is now a data scientist at deloitte but
he's um still publishing with us even
though he uh
he's taken a position in industry so
really fantastic and interesting work
for his dissertation here
where he began a project that was sort
of a data mining
cognitive ontology discovery project
looking at
these task fmri data repositories with
the goal of
mining them to look for clues of how
patterns of bold activity
might delineate categories of
psychological function
following up on some of the you know the
work that i showed you on the
introductory work that i showed you
and the goals of this project here that
was done in collaboration with
andy laird and simon eichoff and others
i think this just came out in
neuroinformatics in 2020
the goal here was to identify
data-driven dimensions of a potential
ontology
based upon the ability of that ontology
to explain
variability between patterns of brain
activity and the approach he took here
was a whole brain representational
similarity analysis
to quantify spatial similarity among
task activation maps
within brain map and here the assumption
is that important features
of existing ontological categories could
be identified in terms of
the amount of how much variance they
explain in task activation map
similarities
so that was the um you know the goal in
this project
so what he actually did in this um in
set of analyses was applied
an unsupervised clustering approach to
all the task activation
patterns that could be derived from the
date frame map database coordinates
and here this analysis included 15 over
15 000 activation maps that yielded
almost 9 000 contrasts that's contrast
between
um you know different conditions in an
fmri test
and they were all of course derived from
activation peak coordinates that are
what are available in the brain map
database and
um this involved a data driven
dimension reduction and a multivariate
distance matrix regression so
um so basically we started here with
uh this is an unsupervised clustering
approach applied to the entire corpus of
the reported
activation coordinates in the brain map
database and he began here with the
construction of
uh activation maps from these reported
peak coordinates of task fmri studies
and then a dimension reduction step
dementia
reduction of these voxel level maps to a
smaller set of networks using sparse
non-negative matrix factorization
and then a clustering of uh basically an
activation map by activation map
similarity matrix based on the
similarities
and network and activation estimates
between
the different uh activation maps from
these coordinates
so there are there were two goals on one
was sort of to
identify how closely the uh
the labels in the um brain map database
really explained differences in task
activation patterns across this huge
database
and the second goal was to see if we
could use a more bottom-up approach to
derive lay-in categories directly from
the data
so the way this worked
well interestingly the unsupervised
clustering of all these
brain map activation maps uh yielded a
four-cluster solution that achieved the
most replicability
using a cross-validation approach um and
this four-cluster solution
could be sort of divided up into these
broad categories of tasks
object viewing complex action affect
introspection social and auditory motor
but note um of course these sort of four
clusters
showed a lot of overlapping the
activation maps that were
associated with them so um you know the
the only cluster that didn't look a lot
like the others was the affect
social cluster which uh resembled a
little bit
uh the default mode network which we'll
talk about uh in a bit
but um what this um type of analysis
suggests that the
um the current oh so i forgot to mention
that the
the current labels in the brain map
database didn't
explain as much of the variance in the
test activation map as these latent
clusters so this suggests that the
current descriptions of cognitive
processes
and the tasks used to elicit them do not
necessarily reflect activation patterns
commonly
observed in the human brain and this is
just to
to note that yeah the four data driven
latent dimensions
explained a greater variation among
activation maps than all the
conventional labels that were already
present
in the brain map database that were used
to categorize the tests in the brainmap
database
and this is just showing that the sort
of test uh you know the default mode and
the negatively correlated
frontal parietal systems is sort of a
ubiquitous pattern
that you see in know resting state fmri
as well
we'll get back to that a little bit
later in the talk
um and this is just a little bit more of
a view of the four
activation profiles and the associated
uh
constructs with each of them and this
will be probably
not so easy to read here but you can
just find the full table in the
paper if you're interested um it's just
another
view of the cluster one two three and
four
in terms of the different task paradigms
and different constructs that
seem to be associated with these types
of activation maps
and um this was just uh you know on the
left showing you how we determined the
number of clusters and there was both a
four and a seven cluster solution that
showed high levels of
of stability but if you look here on the
right the
um the four cluster solution and the
seven cluster
solution derived in a data-driven manner
um really uh explained more variants
than
the traditional brain map labels on the
bottom which are behavioral domain and
test paradigm
for example um so the basically the
similar
similarity matrices here with brighter
colors within the red lines and cooler
colors outside
are showing you that the um there's sort
of more well separated groups of task
activation
maps in the top two uh major seeds than
in the bottom two
meaning that the cluster solution that
he derived in a data-driven fashion was
better able to explain differences in
activation maps than
the labels that have been provided
already by the users
in the brain map database so in summary
here
task paradigm which is one of the
categories that that brainwrap database
includes
seem to explain more variants among test
activation patterns than other
dimensions
um including the latent categories uh
that you saw there and and this means
that like when an individual is
is deciding on particular tasks to study
a particular
construct like working memory for
example that which
paradigm they choose can be very
important because different
test paradigm as a category explains a
lot of the variants among these
activation maps
study id which is what you know which
study the activation maps came from
actually explains about
50 of variance and activation patterns
and the data derived late inactivation
states
we saw here were associated with kind of
known functional systems
frontal parietal saline sensory motor
and default
activation patterns and those four
data-driven
latent dimensions appear to explain
greater variance
among activation maps than all the
conventional ontological dimensions
combined
so these are um just some clues that
that just because we think well we have
a working memory task
or we call it a working memory task you
know it doesn't necessarily
share activation patterns with other
things that are called working memory
tasks
and in fact the uh the labels that we've
been using all along
um you know may need to be revisited and
if we're really looking for
things that explain great variants
amongst brain activation patterns than
the current
categories that are used the current
labels that are used don't seem to be
doing a great job of that
um so that was uh there's another kind
of
way to to ask this question um uh the
the first analysis
was trying to classify activation maps
into separable categories
um and and you know have you know
separable clusters but not sort of
account for commonalities
um between them so there was a lot of
overlap in the clusters i just showed
you however
um that's because the goal of a this
that unsupervised clustering algorithm
was to highlight the differences among
the maps not the commonalities
so the next goal was to sort of explore
the commonalities that were observed
in an exploratory model and here what he
chose to do
was a bi-factor analysis to explicitly
model a general commonality that could
exist across all activation maps
while allowing for subclusters to emerge
within this general pattern
and um and this analysis
whoops so this analysis
required us to accurately estimate
similarities and differences between
activation maps
and the peak coordinate meta-analysis
uh you know that that is permitted by
brain map wasn't quite sufficient for
this job
what we really wanted here was
unthresholded activation maps um
and we found those available in the
neurovault database
as well as the human connectom project
those are two
places where unthresholded active whole
brain activation maps are available so
um you know using all the task
fmr activation maps available in
neurovault and in the human connectome
project
yielded 108 activation maps across a
variety of task domains that we could
use in order to to follow up or to ask
this question
so
oops okay so the approach here was to
first do a data reduction to reduce
the spatial dependence between the
activation estimates across voxels
then we uh enter we conducted a initial
extraction phase in which an initial
factor solution is
estimated and the appropriate number of
factors is determined by parallel
analysis
followed by a by-factor analysis phase
in which the factor analysis
is re-estimated with estimated number of
factors from the initial extraction
phase
and a bi-factor rotation criteria and
finally
testing the fit of other alternative
factor structures using confirmatory
factor analysis so um
how did this work so this is just a test
activation conjunction and test
deactivation conjunction across all
those maps
and as sort of a sanity check you can
see a lot of front or parietal and
um you know insular and cingulate
systems are
uh activated across all tasks and
deactivated
um default mode network regions uh
you know as one might sort of expect
so um
so basically um the first step was a
data reduction as i mentioned and
um this was sort of followed up by the
bi-factor analysis approach where
each task activation map representing
activation
here in red associated with a particular
task is modeled as arising from direct
effects of a single latent general
factor and various lane
sub factors so this was a way of sort of
first accounting for all the
commonalities we see across
task activation maps regardless of task
as well as sort of
sub um you know activation or sub
factors that account for differences
among
different um task activation patterns
so this results of this five factor
analysis suggests
a general factor which explained over 50
of the variance in the activation maps
and again it looks very familiar to
um sort of task positive test negative
or
default mode and um you know frontal
parietal systems that we see sort of uh
across all kinds of um both task and
rest paradigms
but within the you know in addition to
this general factor
we saw as well subtypes which explained
an additional 31
of the variance and activation maps um
so um you know this is suggests that
uh that there is sort of a hierarchical
structure to these um
these patterns that we we have observed
so what else do we know about this
pattern of you know the sort of midline
regions
um with the lateral frontal parietal
regions so this kind of
lateral frontal parietal system is
independently described as a multiple
demand system or domain general task
system or the
extrinsic mode or the executive control
system it just goes by a lot of names
and i'll bring up this point again in a
few slides about what i think about the
problem
of all this nomenclature um and then
there's the sort of midline
regions that are often described as a
default mode network and of course
there's
seems to be antagonist antagonistic
relationships between these sets of
systems
and the the pattern that you see is
pretty ubiquitous if you look at
um you know if you look at uh gradients
of functional connectivity here on the
left with margulies if you look at
co-activation pattern analysis
um you know if you look at the posterior
cingulate and its co-activation again
you get this default mode network
um if you look at correlations of brain
areas with amplitude of eg
alpha rhythm um this pattern of sort of
lateral frontal parietal versus medial
frontal parietal regions is ubiquitous
across different
analysis techniques research questions
tasks or resting stata from rye
so this shows that the single activation
pattern dominating
most observed tasks and from our
activation maps is
is uh this positive negative pattern
we've seen over and over again
um and any cognitive ontology derived
from an exploratory analysis of task
fmri
activation map seems to be um it should
be
dominated by this pattern so
understanding what this pattern
represents
is i think essential for any cognitive
ontology or any construction of a
set of um you know basic principles by
which cognition
is organized in terms of underlying
brain activation
and that all of this brings me to
our sort of current work which uh
centers more
around brain networks and cognitive
neuroscience so i've been talking a lot
about individual brain areas that are
activated or not in response to specific
cognitive tasks or specific instructions
or specific paradigms
but what our lab really focuses on a lot
these days is network approaches and
network neuroscience
um and understanding that you know brain
regions don't really
work in isolation right um and you have
sort of patterns of
frequent co-activation and patterns of
functional connectivity that
um are sort of underlying a lot of what
you see when you look at task fmri data
and one thing we've sort of been trying
to tackle in our
recent work is this problem that you
people refer
to different brain regions belonging to
different brain networks
in a way that's not at all standardized
for example
you know for a region like the anterior
insula um you can look at the cognitive
neuroscience literature and find people
saying well the anterior insulin is part
of the singular particular network the
anterior slowest part of the stainless
network the anterior cell is part of a
ventral attention network
and they may also ascribe overlapping
yet unique roles for these brain regions
within these networks
so um you know i see this as a problem
for the field in terms of
developing a common language developing
taxonomies that we can use to
communicate amongst ourselves um so how
how are we going to define a functional
brain network
given we don't have this consensus at
present and how many functional brain
networks are there these are of course
ill-posed questions but they're sort of
what's uh keeping us
up at night right so um you know i
started
to do this work with thomasio and nathan
spring
last year where we tried to move towards
developing a universal taxonomy of
macroscale functional human brain
networks
i mean i think this just relates a lot
to the work that's being done in the
construction of cognitive ontologies i
think for obvious reasons
and this was a an initial stab at
this difficult question that we took um
and this was just the stance that if we
start to use
similar terminology across studies we
may really make progress in terms of
of human brain mapping and if we don't
have conventions and we don't have
consistent nomenclature we it will just
hinder future progress in this field
so luckily um i was able to convince the
new ohbm best practices committee that
what we really need is to have a
committee of of
individuals working on this topic who
have worked in
connectivity who have worked in um
meta-analysis and who worked in anatomy
to come together and see if we can have
reach a consensus of sorts on this
really
important nomenclature issue so the
first thing
you know we did initially was just look
at what's already out there
and almost every like independent
component analysis or brain parcelation
or
um you know connectivity modeling uh
approach
meta-analytic approach almost everything
identifies something with a visual
back of the brain network um as you can
see and here's steve smith work uh on
the left comparing resting state
networks to the brain map data
base uh um meta analyses
on the right uh thomas joe's uh you know
well-known
functional parsolation in the brain on
the bottom one by evan gordon
and you can see there's always seems to
be something called a visual network or
an occipital network so
maybe that should be one of the things
we include in our taxonomy of networks
when we eventually
build one um you can also almost always
see something
like a somatosensory or somatomotor or
um you know
motor cortex network you can see it in
resting state parcellations here
on different resolutions and you know if
you obviously
parcelate the brain into smaller and
smaller bits you can subdivide these
networks into
subsystems so this seems to be you know
a place we can start
and then you get into these higher level
cognitive association areas
there's been what's been called the
dorsal attention network from
many years of cognitive neuroscience
research showing that sort of top-down
attention
engages these frontal eye field and
posterior parietal areas
and meta-analytic connectivity modeling
suggests that something like this exists
and you can see in green the dorsal
attention network comes out in several
different parcelations of the whole
brain
so these are we think some starting
points um this one and as we get further
along we get into more
controversial perhaps and less agreed
upon um nomenclatures
but you you know people talk about
executive control central executive
multiple demand as i mentioned um this
this network seems to have a lot of
names um
on the right it's uh classified as
frontal parietal
and uh on the left these are from
executive
individuals who refer to these networks
as executive control or central
executive networks
so there just needs to be a little bit
more um agreement upon
what label we should use to to describe
systems or activations or connectivity
within these regions
and here's one that's you know close to
my heart and also
very controversial um you know in my
work i've called the insular acc network
the salience network
um and but there seems to be a lot of
overlap anatomically with what's been
called the ventral attention network
as well as the singular particular
network
and there seems to be a lot more
variability in terms of the spatial
topography here and
uh you know this one will be a difficult
one to
come to a consensus on but the
nomenclature that we're proposing here
is
is more anatomical based and less and
more agnostic
with regards to what we think the actual
function is so if we see mid singular
insular you know connectivity or
activation we might just say okay well
that's a midsigulated solar network
and that will prompt us to um you know
more consistently identify
this uh in future work um and this
of course the default mode network
everybody has known about for many years
um and we're even proposing to rename
that as a medial frontal parietal
network with the idea that
sticking with the anatomical terms will
help us moving forward
um and of course you see fractionation
within this network you see subsystems
um it's not a sort of monolithic entity
so
this is where a lot of work needs to be
done to parse that uh and
what we should call these subsystems for
example so
you know this is one example of a i
would say this was a top-down approach
at
deriving a taxonomy of functional brain
networks this is the initial
uh breakdown that we observe or that we
agreed upon but
again the reason we formed the current
best practices committee was because we
really need sort of wholesale
buy-in from the community in order to
make any taxonomy work
so it doesn't really make sense for me
to call something amid singular and
solar network in a paper
if no one else is adopting that
terminology and no one else knows what
i'm talking about
so these are some of the ongoing
uh challenges and goals for our current
best practice
committee on network nomenclature
and why we still need to refine this
taxonomy it should be obvious i gave a
twitter talk on this
a few months back about what about
network dynamics what about
inter-individual variability and
activation and connectivity what about
subcortical brain regions
what about the idea that networks
fractionate into subsystems and the
hierarchies i just talked to you about
what about these hierarchies
these are all things that you know
require a lot of discussion and so
the group we have assembled is now
meeting once a month to
hopefully tackle these issues and see
where we get
and i think one of the things that will
make
this program or this goal hard to
achieve
is that networks don't just kind of stay
in one place and do the same thing
from moment to moment there's really a
nice theoretical
paper by marshall messelmbeck from the
90s talking about how cognition is
subserved by
interconnected neural networks and
complex behaviors mapped at the level of
multi-focal neural systems rather than
specific anatomical sites so even
you know back in the day before fmri we
knew that it wasn't as simple as one
brain region does one
cognitive process um you know multiple
brain regions contribute to multiple
processes
um and you can see that even with uh you
know a neuropsychological approach
we also know um that the function of a
brain region
and brain area can often depend on the
status of other connected areas this was
the idea of
of neural context put forth by randy
macintosh so
a set of nodes here for example the gray
nodes um
might behave in a particular way when
the black nodes are there
activated but behave in a different way
when the black nodes in b are activated
so this context is important for the
function
um and lastly something we're very
interested in is dynamics and how
regions change
raid regions change their affiliation
over time in the matter of
you know seconds and probably even
milliseconds um and
so a network of course needs to be
understood in terms of the interactions
between multiple brain regions as they
unfold temporally so
um i think because of all of these
issues with respect to dynamics and many
to many mapping of brain
region to function all of these issues
will make it
really difficult to arrive at a taxonomy
or
um you know ontology of brain networks
but
you know nevertheless will will uh
persist
so this is uh you know just a short
overview of how i think neuroinformatics
um can contribute to the formation of
cognitive ontologies
this work was really done by taylor bolt
um and
you know congrats to him for uh pushing
our lab into this direction
um and angie laird has been a great
collaborator um
simon ikoff thomas joe and nathan spring
um and of course the funding sources
have um
you know made this uh you know all
possible in in many ways
so i wanted to just close by saying um
you know vote
like your life depends on it because
that's been the only thing on my mind
for the last few weeks and i just
thought
um if we haven't yet um please do and
uh this is our you know the only hope
that keeps us going at this point
and uh now i'm in san diego on
sabbatical so this is um
this is my sort of morning view and uh
i'm
i'm happy to to leave the rest of the
time for questions and want to say
thanks
again very much for this kind of
invitation and for uh providing me the
opportunity to share some of this
this work that i've been very excited
about i'm happy to take any questions
now
um i'll hand it back over to you jack
thank you lucina that was a
fantastic overview of uh cognitive
ontologies many of the challenges which
exist
and uh it's just a an area which i
have observed either either been
involved with those discussions
or observed for many years and uh you're
absolutely right it's a
a very challenging problem um
and one of the things i think you kind
of i want to encourage our
data science innovation lab participants
to send in any questions via the chat
but while we're waiting for a few um i
was
very you you touched on a couple of key
things
you have the kind of the expert opinion
about how the ontology ought to be
constructed and
i remember you mentioned russ poldrack a
number of times and he's a
a colleague and friend and uh he has
mentioned to me uh several times it's uh
trying to get a bunch of psychologists
to agree on
what to call things uh you can maybe get
them to agree on the topmost
layer of the ontology but you get about
two layers in
and it becomes a probabilistic fog of
what people are going to call it
and um so there's this sort of lack of
consensus with regard to
these um kind of psychological
constructs and you kind of mentioned
um some things about the um uh
the uh um what did i have in my notes
kind of the labeling of various tasks
and this sort of reminded me of you know
what you call
something and what it actually measures
may be two different things this notion
like construct validity
um what is your feeling about how we can
kind of clean some of that
up in order to make some of these
challenges a little more tractable
yeah i mean that's exactly you hit the
nail on the head i know you've been
working
in this area as well over the years and
we're sort of new to it so i
i haven't tried to do the difficult task
um that you know russ and others have
been doing which is to try to get
scientists to agree that okay this task
measures this construct
and um and you know this one instead
measures that
i haven't been involved in those
discussions and um
and to be completely honest the the bit
that i have like in the construction of
the ardoc
uh cognitive domain um it's been
frustrating because so much of it
is ego driven you know if you spent your
20 years of your career
building up a task to study working
memory and suddenly someone tells you
well
if you look at it this way it's not
really studying that at all it's
studying this other thing
i think people are often really um
loathed to give up their favorite task
or to
concede that they're not measuring a
pure construct the way they thought they
were
um so that i think that has to sort of
give way a little bit to
but what do the data tell us you know uh
the the kind of thing taylor was doing
it looking at similarity across
activation maps
is one way to do it like if if they're
measuring similar
things do they activate you know uh
similar brain regions that's one way of
thinking about it right
um so but they know it's not the only
way of course they're
just because regions are activated
similarly doesn't mean there isn't a
pattern within there that could differ
differentiate um so as many people know
there's there's a lot of
patterns within voxels of activation
that could again be discriminative
so um i feel like everyone you know the
field we all need to kind of take a step
back and say well is the goal
to be right about what is working memory
or is the goal to
come to a consensus where we can all
speak a common language and move forward
and uh you know um be a little bit more
um clear in in what we're saying when we
use a particular
terminology so i actually do think we're
getting towards that but
um slowly
it sounds like an advertisement for the
use of data science to help
some of this stuff out doesn't it i
would say that yeah
one of the things which is kind of
interesting and maybe you have a comment
on this as well is that um
a lot of these data driven or
computational topic modeling
type approaches um they they create a
reality
from what they're given yeah and we see
these biases creep in we see this kind
of
particularly in machine learning and ai
kind of applications for like face
recognition
that certain ethnic groups don't get
represented properly don't get
identified in the right way
and obviously this sort of thing you can
see how this might get baked into
any sort of data science application of
these very rich
uh data sets how can do you have any
idea about how some of these data-driven
approaches uh for cognition can be more
robust or at least
honest about the potential biases that
exist and it might be driven by what's
trendy in the literature
and you know they drive these things
like you said there's some egos involved
always yeah this is a great question
that's so important for
a lot of uh reasons um in terms of
equity uh
and i think the the best i mean you
cannot guard against human biases
because they exist on so many levels but
what you can do is
build the most diverse teams um you know
if you have
programmers from all over the world and
different
you know ethnic backgrounds they'll be
more likely to notice
when these biases creep into an
algorithm and they'll be more likely to
test against
those kinds of things so you know having
these diverse teams is
is critical for the science it's not
just the right thing to do
um absolutely um one other thing is uh
you know there's other kinds of biases
though as well one being like
publication bias and so when you draw
from
a literature or from a database that is
leveraging a lot of
different results from around the field
you can get biases because people just
publish stuff that's statistically
significant so things that
aren't significant which would greatly
inform your ontology you just don't even
see them and so again you've
created a reality out of stuff that's
statistically significant
is that helpful exactly um
this is the file drawer problem uh what
i've been
heartened by is the um the emergence of
these new journals i think neuro image
has one
now coming out their image reports um
and aperture the new ohbm journal
there's so many journals that are now
realizing the need for
reporting all results you know good bad
and ugly
because that that's what you need in
order to
um get a full picture of what people are
actually finding it doesn't help if only
20 of studies get published because
those are the
ones people label as interesting it i'm
more of a fan of you know publishing
everything somewhere because publishing
is the way you communicate
what you did and it just because what
you did wasn't the most exciting thing
doesn't mean that other people don't
need to know that you did it
[Laughter]
absolutely it might stop them from going
down a road or it might put them on a
different path to explore
you know something that hasn't gotten a
lot of uh
attention but yeah i agree with you
completely that this file drawer problem
makes it hard for data science because
you can only do a meta-analysis or
you can only do a data-driven approach
on data that exists or it's published
so if there were you know no there's no
studies in the brain map database that
are not published right
well there's a whole sociology about uh
data sharing uh
in neuroscience i was the tip of the
spirit of that for a little while i
could tell you horror stories but um
it's uh it's just a very interesting
thing it's i'm pleased to see
these journals taking this on um and
trying to do something about that i
think that's a positive step
well one thing i wanted to ask you about
is um something about the um the
stability of these networks
um and how reproducible are they um
this is not only from a empirical point
of view
um and a replication point of view but
also in terms of the analytic procedure
which is used to identify them many
times people use the
independent components analysis method
to be able to
partition these networks into their
different
components from the data there's some
uh mathematical challenges though with
some of the most widely used
methods which they sort of take a guess
at to the initial state of the weighting
matrix that produces the independent
components analysis result
um the challenge there is that while it
may converge
after that random guess it may converge
on a particular network structure that
totally satisfies the matrix equations
it's supposed to satisfy
if you run it again you'll get a
different guess and you'll get a
different solution
and even if you average across all those
potential
uh solutions it's not representative of
what's actually going on and i guess
this
uh brings to me the stability of these
and whether or not they can actually be
truly called functional networks if they
vary so greatly
not only within a person but between
people right you get the idea
yeah yeah it's just such a great
question it's so important i i would say
it
the the bigger question here is um
is almost uh you know it's the same
question of you know how many networks
are there
so and that of course any kind of
uh data-driven clustering solution you
can either determine the number of
clusters you can say i want 20
independent components i want 100
independent components you can ask the
algorithm to automatically estimate the
number of clusters so
it's a clustering problem as much as
anything else right
so it's not unique to brain networks or
brain regions that
user-defined clusters could be what
approach or
you know data-driven clusters could be
another protein then you have to
evaluate the stability of the clusters
and you have
some metric for doing that and you might
get a different number based on which
metric you use
so i think these are you know um
problems that are
not unique to the question here we have
about networks um you know clustering
and how many there
are what's the best solution that's a
problem generally right
for anyone doing anything like this
so i then it's like which metric do you
trust enough
what's amazing to me is the um
consistency of
networks independent of whether you do
you know a resting state kind of
breakdown or a task meta-analysis or
what's what's
what's surprising to me is that at a
given level let's say i i want 10
parcels or 10 networks at a given
resolution there seems to be a good
amount of consistency between
um you know different approaches and
different data sets
and different techniques and not of
course they're not identical from one to
the next
but you know at a given resolution it's
it's
heartening to see a good amount of um
stability as it were so i mean for
example there's almost nothing you could
do
there's almost no ica you could run that
wouldn't give you some kind of default
mode network
yeah which is heartening it means you
know something is there
it can break down certainly it can be
subdivided but you know
it seems like there's something about
the brain that lets it settle into this
state so you know there's hope is what
i'd like to
say yeah well it's uh some of the um
our participants in our
data science innovation lab are asking
about the stability
and changes in these networks over the
lifespan and i know that
you've mentioned some of the work of
michael gracias and he had done some
work
kind of a long time ago now that looking
at the variation between people who have
alzheimer's disease in contrast to those
who are otherwise
healthy agers in the context of their
default mode network and changes
do you do you see that this is also
something we should be looking at is the
changes in these networks as they
uh alter their structure over time
uh 100 and you know we do lifespan
network development
in my lab is one of the things we're
interested in
and the all of the parsilations i showed
you in the last few slides are done on
adult
subjects and the assumption is well
that's how the brain is parsley but of
course anyone who does developmental
work knows that
you have changes going from infancy to
childhood to adolescence to adulthood
um in the spatial topography and the
connectivity within in between networks
these are these are
processes that develop and again change
with aging and with disease so
of course this is this is critical to
understand there have been
as far as i know no attempts yet to
parse
the brain in these um you know uh in
these ways across the lifespan
in order to say well does this parcel
sort of change from childhood to
adulthood
at the whole brain level i think people
have done this at like individual brain
regions
um and i think i know a group in western
ontario who is
working on this we're looking at age
bins let's say for example five to eight
and eight to twelve and twelve to
fifteen and looking at how
whole brain organization in terms of the
particulation changes
in those um in a stepwise manner uh
there's other ways of doing it
and i think uh the availability of large
data sets to do this kind of analysis is
really what's what we're
waiting on i think there are some data
sets but you know not at the
level that there are for hcp and the
other like normal adult samples so as
soon as we get more developmental
samples
across the lifespan this will be super
important to address how can we
integrate functional networks with other
means for measuring networks for example
diffusion tensor imaging where you have
a measure of structure
that could be used to guide and maybe
inform
the functional networks they're being
extracted
yeah i mean the the multimodal
integration part is something that is so
tricky because on the one hand you want
to say well okay these
these two approaches let's say structure
and function converge
but on the other hand why should they
converge they're measuring completely
different things you know axons versus
statistical uh relationships between
fluctuations of both signals so
so when they do converge you say great
these these are telling us the same
thing when they don't
there's a million reasons why they
couldn't and one thing we found early on
was that um structure and function
like let's say diffusion metrics and
functional connectivity
are high are seem to be very correlated
in the adult brain but when you look at
children
like let's say seven to twelve there's
very low there's non-significant
correlation between
structural and functional connectivity
this is something we noticed a while ago
and
so something is happening you know
something's developing what comes first
structure or function
you get into you know all of these
chicken and egg questions um not not to
say we don't care about this but we
haven't made uh progress
in this or our lab hasn't made progress
in the multimodal integration
domain but i think others have vince
calhoun's group and others have really
thought about this more seriously
do you think there's any sort of uh um
opportunity for people who are
developing
more uh comp i guess complete models of
brain networks that are more than just
correlative that this
is correlated with that it's rather it's
a solution to
a say a physical like a physical network
where you have you know
a source and you have a you know another
source and there's a wire between them
and you could model the properties of
the wire
and the signal that travels over that
are there any opportunities for
those people oh yes in fact i
i before this the last international
trip i took was a
conference in nepal that was a
computational um neuroscience conference
with
you know victor yerza and michael
brakespire and all these great people
and
my plan for sabbatical was to go visit
michael brakespeare in australia
and then visit gustavo deco in barcelona
that was my original plan
obviously the reason for that was
because of just what you said i think
computational
modeling is the only way you can do this
linking of different levels and
really testing what parameters affect
what you know um what outputs
and so my whole plan was to spend my
year
instead of in san diego to spend it with
those labs
in those nice locations um
and and i'm hoping that the work that
those groups are doing
um are going to feed into you know these
these questions of how many networks are
there and how do they change over time
um because those are the only ways in
which you have complete control over all
the
the different variables um and
unfortunately i'm not doing that as you
can see
but that doesn't mean that it won't be
done eventually
international multi-hemispheric travel
is going to have to be put on hold
on hold exactly a little while longer i
think on that note i want to thank you
lucina for uh providing us with this
great overview of this very interesting
area of cognitive ontologies and
uh the role of data science and helping
to identify
the structure and organization of these
different cognitive constructs and what
that means for the brain
and for the data science that it's going
to take to be able to make some traction
um so thank you so much we really
appreciate chatting with you today thank
you
so such a pleasure and uh yeah good luck
to everyone
excellent and uh i want to thank
everybody who joined us
and uh we'll look forward to seeing you
uh next friday for the next edition of
our
data science innovation lab seminar
series thank you everybody
have a great weekend